hey this is interesting I've talked
before about a tool called the de
feasibility test that can be a useful
tool when we're talking about politics
and I first heard about it I believe
from Peter Boghossian and then I learned
about some other versions of it from
others and the idea is to interject and
sort of slow down a conversation that
might be going nowhere or where you're
not likely to make any progress by
asking what evidence would make you
change your position so if we were
debating abortion for example I might
say someone who is an anti-choice ER
against abortion what evidence if I
could present it to you would get you to
change your mind about this issue and
they might say well if you could prove
you know fetus isn't a person or they
might say if I learned God didn't exist
then I might change my mind about
abortion it's not so much about what the
answer is specifically but about getting
them to think like is there actually
something that would change your mind or
are you irrationally tied to this idea
are you tied to this idea not because of
anything factual so evidence doesn't
even really matter that's the the sort
of gist of the de feasibility test and
CNN host John Berman ran the de
feasibility test on former Trump
communications director Anthony
scaramouche II and skerin Moochie
completely imploded in the sense that he
rambled for minute after minute after
minute not answering the question the
question was what could Trump do to make
you Anthony scaramouche II stopped
supporting him and look at how long like
I'm not even gonna play at all because
it goes on so long look at how long
scaramouche II just rambles on without
actually answering the question here as
we see here this morning do you still
support President Trump yeah course I
support hey John I'm a very John I'm a
very loyal guy remember I got fired two
years ago and the question is Anthony
then if the answer is yes I understood
what the president's morning what would
it take and what would it take for you I
do to stop supporting the president I
well III think he's going in a direction
and I said this a couple of weeks ago on
your air he's going in a direction where
there's a very large group of people
that actually want to support him
they were actually begging him to give
us reasons to support you he's going in
a direction where I guess he doesn't
want that support or he wants people to
have this twisted like a pretzel loyalty
test with him where he's going to do
things that are not making any sense but
I want you to go out there and sort of
defend it okay and so III think there's
a large group of people that are gonna
stop doing that and then eventually
people to say look I'm sorry the value
system and the rhetoric does not
outweigh the policies okay and so at
some point that will happen and has not
happened for me yet but there's a lot of
us out here it's not it's not just me
I'm a little bit more vocal perhaps a
tinge more courageous to admit it but
trust me it's former White House
administration officials it's former
cabinet members its former people in the
American military it's not it's not just
me it's not like I'm the only one I may
be the only one saying it but trust me
there's a very large group of people if
he keeps it up they'll say okay the
policies they're great but you know what
this sort of rhetoric and this sort of
disunity sort of stuff is overpowering
the policy so scare Moochie has no
answer he just repeated that confusing
thing over and over again and he's
reduced to sort of a blubbering and
stuttering mess really nicely done by
John Berman not that it's that complex
of a technique you just say Oh what
would get you to change your mind about
that now it's common that in many
situations if you ask this to someone
what evidence if I could present it to
you would it would change your mind very
often people don't immediately have an
answer but sometimes again the point is
not to have an answer but to get the
person thinking about whether they are
blindly or irrationally attached to a
position for lots of these trumpets the
answer actually is to this question
nothing nothing would get them to
reconsider their support for Donald
Trump I had a funny caller must have
been maybe like a year ago might have
even been a year and a half ago on the
show big Trump is who started by saying
to me on the phone if Trump doesn't
build the wall during his first term he
doesn't have my support in 2020 and
within about a minute I
said much more concretely so you said if
Trump does not build the wall before
2020 you don't vote for him in 2020 is
that right and the trumpet on the phone
immediately started hedging and saying
well I mean it depends on why he doesn't
build it if he doesn't build it because
Democrats get in the way then that's
different it sort of depends and then we
very quickly figured out actually there
really wasn't anything that would stop
him from voting for Trump in 2020
because any failure of Trump or apparent
failure of Trump he was going to after
the fact that tribute blamed for to
someone else in the case of the wall it
was going to be Democrats so this is a
really good question for exposing
dogmatic ideologues and then another one
that can be productive this one my
friend Jay Tomlinson hosted the best of
the left podcast told me about this one
why do you think I hold this position on
a particular issue so it's much harder
for people to say your position is
basically because you're a [ __ ] that
you've come to this conclusion or you're
a bad person when you're starting to
have a conversation about an issue you
actually say to someone okay let's talk
about health care you know my position
before we start talking about it why do
you think I have the position I have
about health care and it is much more
difficult for people to attribute bad
faith when you actually say to them tell
me how you think I arrived at my
conclusion if you've had success with
either or both of these techniques let
me know maybe during live calls later on
this week I would love to hear from from
folks who have actually tried out some
of these tactics